In fact, interdomain routing can oscillate indefinitely. To see why,
consider the following 4 AS topology, where each AS specifies
preferred paths, presumably via local preference. So each AS prefers
the AS in the clockwise direction, rather
than the shorter, direct path. Now it's pretty
easy to see that there's no stable
solution. Let's suppose that we started off with
everybody selecting the direct path. Well, in this case, any one of these ASs
would notice that it has a more preferred path. So for example, AS1 would see
that because AS3 has picked the direct path, then, in fact, it could prefer
1 3 0. Now we enter into
a situation where oscillations can occur indefinitely. Similarly,
here now AS3 sees that it has a more preferred path, 3 2 0, so it might
switch to that. In doing so, it breaks AS1's path. 1 3 0 no longer
works. So AS1 has to switch back to
its less preferred direct path, but now we're
in the same situation all over again. Because
now AS2's preferred path becomes available via 1,
so AS2 now reroutes, and AS3's most preferred path, 3 2 0, no longer works. So
it must switch to the direct path. Now,
it's very easy to see that this oscillation
continues ad infinitum. This particular pathology was first
discovered by Varadhan, Govindan, and Estrin, in a
paper called persistent route oscillation in interdomain routing,
in 1996. Later, Tim Griffin formalized this pathology and
derived conditions for stability. Those stability conditions
came to be known as a BGP
correctness property called safety. It turns out,
that if ASs follow the ranking and export
rules that we discussed, that safety is
guaranteed. But, there are various times when
those rules are violated. Business relationships, such
as regional peering, and paid peering can occasionally
cause those conditions to be violated. So as it
turns out, to this day, BGP is not guaranteed to
be stable in practice, and many common practices result
in the potential for this type of oscillation to occur.